that's you listen to that voice who is
that singing Shawn who's going to be
nominated for top honors for the 61st
Grammy Awards we're about to announce
the major categories such as album of
the year best of the artists and record
of the year right here in studio 57 we
are really excited about this because in
the Toyota green room with artists who
will open the Avalos Shawn Mendes he's
known for hits like you are in my blood
side he is one of the young guys
something like oh it's true he's one of
the youngest artist ever to achieve
three number-one albums actress and
singer janelle monae is a six-time
Grammy nominee thank you very much NPR
called her an artistic genius with her
latest project it's called dirty clean
that's right Grammy winner I love you -
Alyssia Cara was the only woman this
year to win a major Grammy Award she was
named best new artist and Zane Lowe he
knows the music business he's alpha
music's creative director and host none
of you all are strangers to this day and
what it's like but I always get a kick
out of when people artists say I wasn't
up I had no idea he I had to get these
calls what is it like for you on this
morning when you could possibly be
nominated Shawn than this what's it like
what are you feeling what are you
thinking I was waking up pretty much
every hour on the hour yes it's it's
nerve-wracking but I mean yeah it is
it's a really amazing day though and he
just told us we'll see that he's learned
a new thing you know you now know how to
yes this is great I learned how to
French braid and who taught you my mom I
didn't know we were gonna be talking
about this but yeah they were talking
one or two I could French braid your ear
yeah you got best new artist last year
of course you remember that moment what
are you thinking today nervous announce
the names and I was like it's just I
know how those people and Janelle Monae
they were saying that this album for you
is different like anything you've ever
done dirty computer because in 30
seconds or less because no I mean I
think that dirty computer
not just about me and the different
aspects of who I am but it's about a
community of people of marginalized
voices that I wanted to highlight and
celebrate and Zane Lowe you're feeling
good on this day excited I'm around some
amazing artists I'm hanging out with you
you got the last word we're gonna take a
break you know right when we come back